for the master the rule of war on the
unleashing of the attack of the sons of
light against the company of the sons of
darkness the army of belly ow against
the band of Edom Moab and the sons of
Amon and against the army of the sons of
the east and the Philistines and against
the bands of the kitten of Assyria and
their allies the ungodly of the Covenant
the sons of Levi Judah and Benjamin the
exile zin the desert shall battle
against them all their burns when the
exiled sons of light returned from the
desert of the people's to camp in the
desert of Jerusalem and after the battle
they shall go up from there the king of
the Khitan shall enter into Egypt and in
his time he shall set out in great wrath
to wage war against the kings of the
north that his fury may destroy and cut
the Horn of Israel this shall be a time
of salvation for the people of God an
age of Dominion for all the members of
his company and of everlasting
destruction for all the company
the confusion of the sons of japheth
shall be great and Assyria shall fall
and suffered the Dominion of the Katyn
shall come to an end and iniquity shall
be vanquished leaving no remnant for the
sons of darkness there shall be no
escape the sons of righteousness shall
shine over all the ends of the earth
they should go on shining until all the
seasons of darkness are consumed and at
the season appointed by God his exalted
greatness shall shine eternally to the
peace blessing glory joy and long life
of all the sons of light during the
remaining 33 years of the war the men of
renown though summoned to the assembly
together with all the heads of family of
the congregation shall choose for
themselves fighting men for all the
lands of the nations they shall armed
for themselves warriors from all the
tribes of Israel to enter the army year
by year when they are summoned to war
but they shall armed and no man for
entry into the army during the years of
release for they are Sabbath's of rest
for Israel in the 35 years of service
the war shall be fought - during six the
whole congregation shall fight it
together and during the remaining 29
years the war shall be divided during
the first year they shall fight against
erina hareem during the second against
the sons of lord
during the third against the remnant of
the sons of aram against us and Hull and
toga and Mesha beyond the Euphrates
during the 4th and 5th they shall fight
against the sons of arpachshad during
the 6th and 7th against all the sons of
Assyria and Persia and the east as far
as the great desert during the 8th year
they shall fight against the sons of
Elam during the 9th against the sons of
Ishmael and cateura in the 10 years
which follow the walls shall be divided
against all the sons of ham according to
their clans
and their habitations and during the ten
years which remain the war shall be
divided against all the sons of japheth
in their habitations on the day when
they get him fool there shall be battle
and terrible carnage before the God of
Israel for that shall be the day
appointed from ancient times for the
Battle of destruction of the sons of
darkness at that time the Assembly of
gods and the hosts of men shall battle
causing great carnage on the day of
calamity the sons of light shall battle
with the company of darkness amid the
shouts of a mighty multitude and the
clamour of gods and men to make manifest
the might of God and it shall be a time
of great tribulation for the people
which God shall redeem of all its
afflictions none shall be as this from
the sudden beginning until its end in
eternal Redemption on the day of their
battle against the key team they shall
set out for carnage in three Lots shall
the sons of light to brace themselves
and in three Lots shall bali owls hosts
gur itself to thrust back the company of
god
and when the hearts of the detachments
of foot soldiers faint then shall the
might of God fortify the hearts of the
sons of light and with the seventh lot
the mighty hand of God shall bring down
the army of Valley Isle and all the
angels of his kingdom and all the
members of his company in everlasting
destruction the priests the Levites and
the heads of the tribes they shall rank
the chief priests below the high priest
and his vicar and the 12 chief priests
shall minister all the daily sacrifice
before God whereas the 26 leaders of the
priestly divisions shall minister in
their divisions below them in perpetual
ministry shall be the Chiefs of the
Levites to the number of 12 one for each
tribe the leaders of their divisions
shall minister each in his place below
them shall be the chiefs of the tribes
together with the heads of the family of
the congregation they shall attend daily
at the gates of the sanctuary whereas
the leaders of their divisions with
their number of men shall attend their
appointed times on New Moon's and on
Sabbath and in all the days of the year
their age being fifty years and over
these are the men who shall attend at
Halle costs and sacrifices to repair
sweet for the good pleasure of God to
atone for all his congregation and to
satisfy themselves perpetually before
him at the table of glory they shall
arrange all these things during the
session of the year of release